[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to another episode of the
outdoor boys YouTube channel today we're
gonna talk about ninja discrimination
yes here in the Commonwealth of Virginia
there are many laws designed to
discriminate against those people who
choose to self-identify as ninjas
Virginia Code 18.2 308 specifically bars
the concealment of ninja throwing stars
numchucks and sudoc hence I'm going to
do something to try to make this
Commonwealth of Virginia a little bit
more open a little bit more tolerant of
those of the ninja orientation we are
going to build a ninja throwing star
bandolier so that you can legally and
hopefully express yourselves as ninjas
in addition to fighting anti ninja
discrimination we're also going to be
giving away some epic prizes lots of
ninja weapons are gonna be given away so
stay tuned at the end of this video I'm
gonna show you guys how you can win what
you can win all the details all right
let's get started first things first
we're gonna need some harness leather
and lots of it there we go there is a
big chunk of cow skin right there folks
[Music]
last year when I came home with 50
pounds of tan harness leather my wife
questioned whether I needed it all I
think those of you who follow my channel
will agree that it's been a good buy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright let me show you what we got so
let me show you how my open-carry
ninja throwing star bandelier system
works yeah you take your ninja throwing
stars and you put them away and conceal
them and put them in your pocket you
have committed a class 1 misdemeanor in
the state of Virginia punishable by up
to 12 months in jail
so to avoid legal issues our ninja
friends can now open carry their ninja
throwing stars which is perfectly legal
now yes this magnetic bandolier system
allows you to store your throwing knives
your small and full-sized ninja throwing
stars and you are just ready to go look
at this in fact any of your throwing
weapons can be stored on the magnetic
ninja throwing star bandolier system
there you go there's even a space down
here for your throwing sticks and a
little sheath built in for more throwing
knives look at that nice now I know you
guys are thinking this is one sexy piece
of ninja wear but it's not just
fashionable it's functional too so let's
take this out to our ninja throwing star
throwing range and see how it performs
ah you didn't see me coming cuz of my
ninja skills yeah that's right and
remember it's not just about ninja
throwing stars
now one of the great things about this
ninja throwing star bandolier system is
it so versatile if you're super ripped
like me or dwayne johnson you can often
get poked by these larger ninja throwing
stars because they they stick out over
the side of the bandolier so you can go
down to half size ninja throwing stars
and they fit quite comfortably on the
bandolier and you won't get poked when
you're doing ninja rolls or climbing
through air ducts to assassinate your
foes now remember nothing ever says that
you have to use ninja throwing stars you
can use shooter Ken's throwing knives
throwing sticks katanas sized commas
whatever you like just remember mix and
match your bandolier to your social and
assassination needs and as always don't
forget your throwing sticks whether
wearing them in your hair or openly in
your bandolier they're a great little
weapon I promise you I do a giveaway and
we're gonna do just that I'm gonna give
away this bandolier with a set of ninja
throwing stars and the axes and the
throwing sticks to one of you
subscribers just make sure you're a
subscriber click share share this video
on any website social media platform
Instagram Facebook YouTube whatever and
leave a comment something ninja related
or a funny joke or give me a good
suggestion for future videos of my
favorite comment I will go and give this
bandolier system to that person ok but
that's not all
if I can get 10,000 likes I'm gonna give
away some of my extra ninja throwing
stars if you're under 18 I'm not gonna
be sending this stuff to you without
your parents permission for
if they say no we'll work something out
we'll make sure you get some sort of
prize but hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video you talk to it was almost fun
if you want to see more videos like this
make sure you click that like button and
don't forget to click Subscribe and
click that Bell button so you get
notified when we put out new videos we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning thanks for watching have a great
day